hello everyone and welcome to uh an
incredible game uh from the uh uh feed
hs.com grand swiss uh it's alexander
pretka of russia versus knowledge back
yakub of uzbekistan and it's uh really a
masterpiece so a game you guys will love
this when it comes as a suggestion from
the ecoslav nimitz he suggested it on
twitter uh just in the right moment when
the uh miraculous move took place so uh
without further ado let's check it out
as there's quite a lot to enjoy and
there will be two very very interesting
pause the video moments so uh alexander
with the white pieces opens with d4 uh
sorry about that
uh we have knight to f6 by notrebec uh
c4 we have g6 knight to c3 and bishop to
g7 so the start of a normal king's
indian defense uh we have e4 and d6 now
we have h3 going for the maco gonna
variation of the of the kings indian
and the black castles we have bishop to
g5 and now knight to c6 so black
taunting whites to advance those pawns
in the center white plays knight to f3
and now h6 challenging the bishop now
the bishop can go back to h4 or you
might consider something like bishop to
e3 even d2 but of course that's a very
very rare so bishop to e3 and now black
strikes in the center with e5 and now
white grabs more space in the center and
advances his pawn to d5
here although trading is possible no one
actually ever played this in this
position because if you play chess like
this captures captures then trade queens
the whoa
uh trade queens then what uh i mean what
what are you even doing here you play
rook to d1 and i mean
the game is instantly boring so instead
white grabs more space in the center d5
and now uh most often in this position
knight to e7 is played but here black
goes for knight to d4 and the
interesting thing about this is that uh
knight to d4 is the engine's absolute
favorite move but this is why the
engines are engines and the humans are
not engines as you'll see in this game
so knight to d4 we have knight capture
sunday for e captures on the e4 so uh
temporary pawn sacrifice here or maybe
not a temporary one and now queen
captures on d4 if you capture with the
bishop then the e4 uh pawn can be
captured just knight captures an e4 and
if knight captures an e4 there are many
uh ways for black to play this like
queen h for attacking the knight rook e8
can come f5 can come the white king is
still in the center of the board so
maybe capturing with the bishop isn't
all that impressive so queen captures an
uh d uh on d4
attacking this uh defending d for pawn
and now
what do you do about this the bishop is
x-raying the queen on d4 and the black
of course tries to take advantage of
this knight to g4 and now the queen is
attacked once the queen moves we're
gonna pick up the bishop on e3 and there
is one game in the database that reached
this position where queen 32 was played
in black happily captured the bishop for
the price of one pawn he has a dark
square bishop white doesn't and he will
have a
very very pleasant game however in this
game white does not step back white says
all right you have your queen i'm going
to play h captures on g4 and this is the
magic moment where vehicle suggested
this game on twitter uh saying that uh
well am i already covering this game and
uh i i started enjoying it and i was
very very interested uh in how the game
would continue because okay white has
compensation it's two pieces uh but
there is much more than that because
material is really not the issue in this
game so of course the queen has to be
captured bishop capture
we have bishop characters on d4 and now
white has the very simple plan of rook
captures on h6 followed by rook to h8
checkmate that's it that's why it's
planned and black of course has to
prevent this so king to h7 now the rook
the pawn cannot be captured uh and here
we have bishop to e2 a very important
move um
and it's very hard for black to find the
move because now uh look at all these
light squares there's really no good
developing move for this bishop the
queen doesn't really have any squares
where are you gonna put this rook i mean
no no no good square for the rook uh how
are you getting the other rook into the
game so what uh okay black can play here
your guess is as good as anyone's uh so
here black tried an aggressive move and
he played f5 white king is still in the
center of the board so black will also
profit from uh opening up the position
or maybe you know maybe he won't but
that's what he's hoping for so e
captures on f5 we have g captures on f5
and now
well how do you continue here there is
only one move that gives a white
advantage and that is a rook to h5 this
is what white played and now it's very
very difficult for black to continue to
game if you continue with the standard f
captures on g4 because it doesn't seem
like there's anything wrong with this
move well you've just opened up this
light square diagonal for white slide
square bishop and after bishop the d3
check look at this this is just uh i
mean how how do you play this with black
king g8 we're going to capture on h6 how
do you continue you can throw in a few
checks queen e7 king to f1 i mean you
haven't really done anything now even
the other rook can come into the game
and if bishop f5 trying to eliminate one
of the attackers you don't care just
captures captures and now rook to ha to
check king to f7 and of course rook to
h7 check and now we win back our queen
king to f8 the rook captures king
captures and we have this position where
white has a bishop and the knight for a
rook but also he's up a pawn so it's a
much much better position for for white
easily winning uh
on this level so instead after this rook
to h5 move we have king to g6 and now
how can white continue well white
doesn't even castle to bring the other
rook into the game white continues
playing in great style he plays king to
d2 he says i like my king in the center
you do not have a dark square bishop my
rook on h5 also covers the g5 square so
there's no queen g5 and now rook 8 to h1
is coming so here f captures on g4 now
you're threatening to win the rook so
rook ate the h1 attacking the
uh pawn here and there is no good way to
counter this if you play something like
rook to h8 then we just well we can
either pick up that rook or we could
just continue with bishop to d3 check
and the king hunt begins so there's no
good way or to actually cover that so
instead bishop to f5 we cover this
diagonal and also we need to start
developing our pieces because we have a
queen and we have those rooks that
aren't doing really anything so here
rook captures an h6 with check and now
of course if king to g5 bishop to e3 is
checkmate so our only option is to go up
the board king the f7 was played and now
we have rook 1 to h5 and this is a
beautiful move uh there are other moves
here i mean this position is extremely
complicated and uh well you could make
any move and claim that it's great you
could make any move and claim that it's
like nonsense but i'm gonna show you one
line that's incredibly impressive and
that is bishop to d3
so obviously we're threatening to pick
up the bishop here so black might trade
or might start running away with the
king doesn't really matter let's say
white trades captures captures and now
you want to hide your king here maybe
play b6 maybe hide the king on b7 white
doesn't have a light square bishop now
we play bishop g7 attacked the rook here
and after the rook moves for example
bishop to f6 attacks the queen and once
the queen
joins the seventh rank now comes rook h7
attacking the queen once again and even
after one check we can go knight to e4
and what are you what are you playing
here there's really no good move you can
make uh it's a really uh just a
devastating position uh for black
there's nothing for you to do if rook to
f8 going after the bishop we can just
play rookie seven check king d8 now
we're under the mask of the bishop we
can play rook f7 check king eight now we
can capture here and after king captures
let's say rook hey checking here rook
captures here and now you have a rook
bishop and knight for a queen with
absolutely
zero play here for black there is
nothing black can make here any move
black makes here makes no difference
whatsoever in the position and it will
be an easy win for white so there are
many ways to continue this white
continues with rook 1 to h5 now just
threatening the bishop this way so king
the e7 now the bishop is defended and
now again bishop to d3 is possible but
white goes for a different idea knight
to d1 not the knight is coming to e3
because you can see that this light
square bishop does not have all that
many squares so c5 by black attacking
the bishop just bishop to c3 no no
need to panic here king to d7 and now
finally knight to e3 attacking this
bishop uh and it's um well it's a very
uh
again tricky position because what do
you do with the bishop doesn't really
matter bishop to e4 you could play
bishop to b1 in the game bishop to b1
was played and this allows the whites to
go for a brilliant brilliant maneuver uh
which was not played in the game but you
guys are more than welcome to try and
figure it out so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this
incredible winning move for white while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
almost unspottable move in this
incredibly complicated position and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course king to c1 yes
that's the winning move it's silly but
this bishop really doesn't have all that
many squares now it doesn't matter where
the bishop goes for example if bishop to
e4 we're going to play rook to e6 attack
the bishop again and now the only square
for the bishop available is just to move
that bishop somewhere for example to g2
we can play that but now rook to h7
finally the bishop
removed itself from this diagonal and
now after king the c8 we can play rook
to e7 and there's really nothing you can
play here
or rather even better for example bishop
to g4 just threaten all sorts of nasty
discoveries and after the king moves now
we can play rook to a7 even better
there's no way i mean you you can play
this whatever you play it's completely
lost if queen to c and we we simply pick
up the queen so
you can't even
give up the queen somehow if queen to be
sex guarding this uh even bishop to a5
is an option i mean what what a crazy
position and how if queen captures on a5
not simply rook captures on b7 checkmate
the bishop is covering the c8 square so
uh really an outstanding um
idea but it was not played in the game
similar it was uh in the game bishop
captures on g for uh with check first uh
king to c7 and now f3 so uh white
solidifies the position a little bit but
this also gives black time to
consolidate so queen to e8 uh and now
comes rook back to h1 uh since you want
to play this move at some point but then
this rook might be stranded here for the
moment it's defended by the bishop uh
but let's go after the bishop on b1 so
rook to h1 puts pressure on the bishop
bishop back to g6 and now rook to e1 now
x-raying that queen on e8 so rook the g8
and now defending the bishop now the
queen can move and here comes bishop to
e6 attacking the rook and g8 queen to f8
putting pressure on the rook on uh h6
and now rook e back to h1 and already
you can see that black is once again
struggling for moves here it's very very
difficult to spot a move for example you
could go for some like queen to f4 then
we're gonna see something like rook to
h4 then queen g3 uh but what is the
queen really doing there but in the game
uh rook the e8 was played but this is
now
game over but only if you find one very
specific move from white so feel free to
pause the video once again and find
pretty much the only winning move for
white here while i give you a couple of
seconds
uh for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting any of
the good moves like bishop captures on
g8 like rook to h3 also a fine idea but
the absolutely uh most correct move is
uh rook to h4 rook to h3 is very similar
but we're gonna go with rook to h4 uh
but congratulations to everyone who
found rook to h3 it's pretty much the
same idea and now uh what do you play
here rook the g4 is coming and how are
you getting out of this there's really
no good move you can play here in the
game rook captures and e6 was played but
we're just going to briefly um
cover some options like bishop to f7 you
could play this uh open up the the g
file so you don't meet this with a
double attack on the bishop but still we
can simply play bishop captures queen
capture so rook to h7 and now the queen
is lost rook the g7 doesn't help because
our bishop covers the the g7 square so
of course this would be completely lost
so after rook one to h4 also possible
maybe he's rook to e7 but again now we
just capture on g8 queen captures and
rook to g4 again with uh
just a crushing attack this is again
impossible bishop covers the g7 square
so no point in playing that playing that
so uh black thought all right let's
remove one of white's strongest
attackers and that is the bishop on e6
so rook captures on e6 uh d captures on
e6 and now comes queen to e8
so how can white make progress here well
knight to d5 with check with king to c6
and now knight to f6 attacking the rook
attacking the queen and you can see that
there are very very few moves you can
play here uh you could of course capture
on e6 then just knight captures uh rook
uh so in the game uh queen to e7 was
played uh but it doesn't really help now
you could capture the rook the ideas
maybe some queen to g5 check could pose
some problems for the white king as
maybe some sort of a perpetual can can
be found uh but white just played rook
to g4 and it was in this position on
move 34 uh that um another akubo
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so the rook is
being threatened the the bishop is being
attacked twice there's really nothing
you can do here your only move is
basically queen characters on e6 but
then we just capture the rook and after
queen captures we're going to capture
the bishop as well and now we have two
rooks and the bishop against the queen
with no counter play whatsoever from
black
so really an incredible game and i've
seen uh some games with with a similar
queen sacrifice but never in this
particular position and never
uh well uh it was really really a long
shot i mean white of course had a great
compensation uh because after the
position opened up and uh here
this uh h captures on g4 was played
adjust the absence of the bishop and the
weakness of black's dark squares allowed
white to really create
uh
create well just too many threats for
for black to handle maybe theoretically
it was possible to defend this position
but it's always easier to attack than to
defend and uh this uh kind of reminds me
of uh well not the the game itself but
the idea
of the only game fisher ever played
against uh
mikhail botvinik uh
where the also the position was familiar
it was known and then you know fischer
just found a queen sacrifice out of
nowhere and you know he got a winning
position out of that uh if you still
haven't seen that game i will put a link
to it in the description below it will
be the first uh thing you see yeah so
that's fisher's only game against the
botwinic really a wonderful one uh if
you still haven't seen it so here also
the position has been reached before and
the queen just moved but here the the
bold h captures on g4 and then the the
the party really starts uh so i was very
very happy to see this game hope you
guys enjoyed it as well uh and yeah
that's it always uh suggest great games
like these you can suggest them via
twitter via facebook you know via email
you just anywhere you know in the
comments section of youtube using
hashtag suggestion i always go through
those uh and then you know we we are
able to enjoy games like these
uh so yeah that's the game i really hope
you guys enjoyed it i i definitely
enjoyed it it was really uh you know a
daily improver uh i would like to thank
oliver news the hoodie guy the wind
machine uh tom darrell and michael
kennedy for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day